je sais que le chef de l'État a réagi la
tragédie survenue ce matin en Ukraine
Emmanuel Macron qui se dit attristé par
la mort tragique du ministre de
l'Intérieur décédé dans le crash de son
hélicoptère à beauvary dans la banlieue
est de Kiev à ses côtés sont secrétaire
d'État et en représentant les derniers
bilan communiqués et lourd il fait état
d'au moins 18 morts dont trois enfants
on retrouve tout de suite sur place
Gulliver crack qui est notre
correspondant dans le capital ukrainien
de l'hiver bonjour quelle est la
situation sur place
alors les enquêteurs sont ici en grand
nombre aussi les habitants du quartier
qui sont sous le choc derrière moi vous
voyez la crèche sur laquelle
l'hélicoptère s'est abattu en fait c'est
l'autre côté du bâtiment qui est plus
endommagé mais les enquêteurs nous ont
demandé de dégager de ces lieux là pour
ne pas empêcher leur travail mais
l'hélicoptère a visiblement eu un
trajectoire de l'immeuble derrière moi
vers le jardin d'enfant qui est juste à
côté les
places de jeux de enfants le bilan
s'élève à 18 morts dont trois enfants y
compris donc tout l'équipage et les
personnes qui se trouvaient à bord de
l'hélicoptère dont le ministère de
l'Intérieur son premier adjoint et son
premier secrétaire et puis 9 personnes
se trouvant sur le sol et si les
le choc et je pense qu'il y a au moins
un enfant qui est encore porté disparu
j'ai vu des membres de sa famille
visiblement qui le cherchait encore et
qui disait espérer découvrir que ce
n'est pas lui seul la phrase que j'ai
entendu peut-être que ce n'est pas lui
invisiblement encore avait été trouvé il
me disait peut-être que ce n'était
peut-être que ce n'est pas lui avec avec
cette expression d'espoir c'était
vraiment très dur à entendre
l'ampleur de cette tragédie au coeur de
la guerre et il faut le rappeler
beaucoup de questions donc forcément se
sont posés immédiatement il y a une
enquête un groupe spécial qui était
créée pour enquêter pour tenter dans
d'en apprendre plus sur les conditions
les circonstances de ce drame que
sait-on au moment où l'on se parle
Gulliver
alors surtout les autorités mettent en
garde contre toute spéculation ils
disent on ne connaît pas les causes de
cet accident pour le moment on sait que
il y avait beaucoup de brouillard
au-dessus de gros varie ce matin mais
au-delà de cela
il y a des tests qui circulent sur
Internet et un représentant d'ailleurs
du ministère de l'Intérieur à la radio
mais tu es vraiment en garde contre la
dissémination de ces théories mais
officiellement le procureur général a
déjà ouvert l'enquête et aucune
hypothèse aucun hypothèse ne sera exclue
il y a aussi une demande à tous les
témoins tous les gens dans le quartier
qui ont vu ou entendu quelque chose de
se présenter aux enquêteurs qui
d'ailleurs sont déjà autour de moi en
train
les habitants du quartier pour essayer
de comprendre un peu mieux qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé merci beaucoup Gulliver
Craig au plus près après cette tragédie